so Kim in the last video we started
talking about how slavery has been an
issue in the United States really since
it's since its founding with the
Revolutionary War and we see some images
here of slavery this was a particularly
famous image that really kind of helped
spark indignation
in the North amongst abolitionists
because you can see how this person was
beaten or whipped yes absolutely yeah
and so it's just kind of you know and
today we all took this morally
reprehensible thing but you go back not
too far in the whole scope of history
we're going to the early 1800s and you
know this was something that's debated
it was it was slavery was allowed and a
large chunk of the United States and in
the last video we talked about that this
issue of slavery only got exacerbated
the more territory that was added you
have the Louisiana Purchase in 1803 that
adds all of this territory you start
having states getting carved once you
get a critical population a critical
mass of people in a certain state they
can apply to be or in a certain
territory they can apply to be a state
and as each of these states are added in
they want to get representation it's a
political issue you mentioned how you
know the north they didn't like it on
moral grounds that if it was a slave
state and they also didn't like it on
economic grounds it's hard to compete
economically with slavery while the
south was afraid of losing its its
political power if more free states were
to join the Union and you know in
Compromise of 1820 you mentioned that
well that compromise Missouri is a slave
state Maine gets carved out of
Massachusetts becomes a free state but
that didn't solve the problem that
problem only continues because we only
add more territory yeah I mean most of
the history of the 1800s when it comes
to slavery is a history of putting off
the problem right now Henry Clay becomes
this very famous legislate legislator
because he's good at compromising he's
called the great compromiser so instead
of trying to actually solve the issue of
slavery which many people think of as an
unsolvable problem they're just saying
alright well how can we put off the
conflict over this a little bit longer
and and and just keep doing that you
know in 1836 the territory expands
further or it starts to buy eggs
the expansion is catalyzed further by
the Texas Revolution Texas gets its
independence from Mexico which itself
got independence only a few decades
before that from Spain but so Texas for
a brief amount of time is it's its own
independent country but then it joins
the u.s. its annexed by the US in 1845
so it's more territory for the US and
that was slave territory right yeah so
again this is an area in the south where
most of the reasons that we slavery
existed in the south is because it's a
very fertile agricultural region right
where the things that you grow crops are
very labor intensive so they figure how
are we going to find enough people to
grow these crops and the answer is
they've been importing African slaves
and forcing them to work and the the
annexation of Texas there's border
disputes with Mexico which which leads
to even which another conflict with
Mexico at this time with the US and
Mexico this is the mexican-american war
for from 1846 to 1847 the reason why it
helped bring the slavery issue even more
to a head is that when the u.s. wins it
it gets even more territory it gets it
gets all of this area in the West right
over here right it's more territory and
it's more sort of southern territory
which means that has a high probability
of becoming slave states and so this map
that we looked at earlier in the other
video this this is kind of showing what
the what the u.s. looked like as we as
we exit out of the mexican-american war
we're getting to about 1850 and so what
happens then I mean is it just one
compromise after another at this point
well this is the point where compromise
begins to break down right Henry Clay
again is the architect of what's called
the compromise of 1850 as soon as the
u.s. goes to war with Mexico people in
Congress are wondering our if we get
this territory that we're trying to get
what's going to happen are they going to
be free slaves free states or slave
states and you know
this compromise over free and slave
states has been going on you know for
thirty years since the Missouri
Compromise and you know even longer if
you take it back to 1776 so they're
doing exactly the same thing they're
saying all right well let's try to keep
a balance of power between free states
and slave states except they add in a
couple of provisos that make people
really angry in the 1850s and who gets
angry both I would say slave owners and
abolitionists and anti-slavery activists
in the north so I guess that's what
makes it a compromise a little bit of
something to make everyone angry and so
what what what made what made the what
what made the slave owners angry about a
compromise of 1850
well one of the parts of the compromise
of 1850 apart from deciding whether
these new territories were going to be
slave or free was a part of the act was
called the Fugitive Slave Act and the
Fugitive Slave Act said that it was a
federal offense not to help slave owners
recover so this is something that would
make the the abolitionist angle or the
anti-slavery yeah absolutely both um so
for example if you're maybe living in
Massachusetts you're a white
middle-class person living in
Massachusetts
you don't think slavery is great you
think it's morally wrong but it hasn't
really directly affected your life right
you're hundreds of miles away from the
nearest slave state but now the federal
government says that if there is a
person who has escaped from slavery who
has come to your town it is a federal
offense for you not to help return that
person to slavery those fugitive slave
this is part of the compromise this is
part of the compromise of 1850 it is is
that I could be saying Massachusetts I
could be anti-slavery or I could be even
be ambivalent about it but now I have to
be complicit in it if there's a slave I
can't or if there's someone who's you
know escapes from the south as it was a
former slave
have to actively I can't in any way help
them if I do I could go to jail if I'm a
law officer I have to capture that
person and have to bring them back so
it's kind of forcing people who are
already not happy about slavery it's
kind of bringing it close to that they
have to have to partake in it yeah and
these are people who have very strong
religious convictions this is you know
the mid 19th century as a time when
people feel their religion very strongly
and so there are people in the North who
are Quakers who are otherwise
religiously opposed to slavery who you
know have maybe prayed for the souls of
slaves but it's never been their job to
try to keep someone in slavery before so
that is really infuriating one of the
things that you get out of this is a
really strong backlash of abolitionist
sentiment in the north for example
Harriet Beecher Stowe she's the daughter
of a reverend who's against slavery she
writes the book uncle's Uncle Tom's
Cabin which becomes this smash-hit
what was this ruffle that was about 1852
okay so this is after the compromise of
1850 so people are getting it really is
coming to a head the people in the north
it's they're having to partake in this
because of the Fugitive Slave Act II of
Harriet Beecher Stowe writes Uncle Tom's
Cabin
it makes people even more upset about
the realities of slavery right and in
the South you know they've kind of
gotten away white slave owners in this
time with people saying and you know
slavery is not really my problem I don't
like it but now they're seeing a
concentrated attack a moral and social
attack against slavery in the north and
their response is to become even more
violently in favor of slavery they posed
the idea that slavery is you know not
just something that we could turn turn
our eyes away from but it's necessary
but it's a positive good slavery is
going to actually make the country
better you know if it weren't for
slavery
all of these enslaved Africans African
Americans their their lives would be
worse without us
and so we clear on the the compromise of
1850 and there was a bunch of things
whole - a whole video on the compromise
of 1850 all of the different facets of
it but it's one of its in terms of this
conversation one of its outcomes is
because of the Fugitive Slave Law it
infuriated many of the anti-slavery
abolitionists in the north they became
more entrenched in their positions which
made the southerners more entrenched in
their positions the southerners didn't
necessarily they like the the Fugitive
Slave Law the southerners the compromise
of 1850 it sounds like was it was a
compromise not everyone was happy but it
sounds like it made the anti-slavery
folks more unhappy than the slavery
folks yeah absolutely so it makes the
anti-slavery folks super unhappy but it
also means that now white slave owners
in the south they feel like there's a
target on their heads and so they're
going to dig in even further to make
sure that their interests in slavery are
protected and this gets us to the
election of 1860 which I guess in some
ways was the you know the straw that
breaks the camel's back I guess from a
southern perspective and why is that
well during the 1850s you have all of
these political battles over slavery in
fact it kind of breaks the major
political party of the 1850s the Whig
party so in 1860 some of these leftover
Whigs they reorganize as the Republican
Party and that's this is the first
election with the Republican Party that
we know today
but obviously in 1860 the things that
they're interested in their goals and
aims are completely different and the
Republican Party is a an anti-slavery
party they're deliberately and publicly
against slavery
so they nominate as their political
candidate for 1860 Abraham Lincoln who
is well known in the country for having
been an anti-slavery agitator he's given
many speeches where he's made very
eloquent arguments against slavery and
he's talked about of the future he's
against it I guess on moral grounds but
perhaps even more his own father
wasn't able to be a successful farmer
because he had to compete with with
slave owners right so he you know he's
brought up to hate slavery because it's
a big business that has harmed his own
family's economic future but he comes I
think to his own conclusion that slavery
is morally wrong what he doesn't think
that he can do as president is legally
or constitutionally get rid of slavery
he doesn't think that the Constitution
allows it but he is seen as enough of a
threat by southerners that in many cases
on the presidential ballots in 1860 you
couldn't even vote for Abraham Lincoln
if you wanted to he didn't show up on
the ballot in southern states
nonetheless he still gets enough
electoral votes that he's elected and
then that's what takes us into the real
the real meat of you know catalyzes a
civil war yes stay tuned Abraham Lincoln